the 2011 alumni medal for distinguished
service to columbia university is
presented to Susan Fagan 1974 school of
general studies my first very first day
I walked onto the Columbia campus in
September first 1968 I was 19 years old
I've had one year of college in texas I
was just married I had just been on an
airplane for the first time and I went
to work at Columbia to put my husband
through school at the time and I had an
opportunity to enroll in school of
general studies and so I was working
full-time and going to school part time
I was working in the president's office
as a junior jr. jr. secretary my most
poignant memory about that was a summer
class and anthropology but she was a
fantastic teacher and she said Susan if
you don't do a better job than this on
this paper i am going to fail you I
began to realize that the teacher was
not looking for what she wanted but was
looking for me to make my own
contribution to the material
when I took my first job in development
it was an opportunity for me to move
from sort of the administrative
secretarial rank into sort of a junior
professional rank because it seemed like
a career opportunity when Frank wolf was
the interim dean at general studies in
the 1990s he recruited me to join the
school of general studies Advisory
Council and he asked me for what I
thought was a really big gift and I said
yes to both and I have to say it was
very exciting for me to find myself on
the other side of the table and i love
that i said okay i want to do this
because i can sit with other alumni and
say you know i gave a scholarship let me
tell you what it's meant to me and why I
think that's so important and I hope
you'll join me both the work aspect and
the Alumni Volunteer Park both feel very
personal because when I came back to
Columbia 2002 Lee and I talked about our
experiences as columbia alumni and the
fact that we knew that Columbia needed
to be very different I think the
creation of the columbia alumni
association is really such an important
development for the university to hold
and so having a physical manifestation
of columbia and its alumni i think is
just great having our offices there and
coming in every day through the Welcome
Center and seeing alumni it's just I
think the kind of relationship we should
have and want to have I think there was
a camaraderie among alumni medalist that
I just wouldn't have met
Sara Lee expected study
and I'll remember it more like I
remembers a day I put on the robe and
graduated then all the other times I put
on the robe to represent Columbia
you